[Music]
good ready for what's coming
[Music]
Jackson storm is part of the next
generation of high-tech racing rookie
sensation Jackson Stone jackson storm
storm in a class of his own hey champ
got a good run you have no idea what a
pleasure it is for me to finally beat
you did you say meet or beat I think you
heard me enjoy your retirement you'll
never be the racer you once were you
can't turn back the clock kid but you
can wind it up again the racing world is
changing treadmills Winton's
virtual reality I'm still working on
that and interactive race simulation
I've jumped a barrier
sure you have crash we got some work to
do I am so excited that I get to train
you visualize beating this
the beach ate me every week veteran
racers retire to make room for these
younger faster racers paparazzi you'll
never be as fast to storm but you can be
smarter good luck out there
you're gonna need it I decide when I'm
done
you are not winning this
storm
[Applause]
good luck out there champ you're gonna
need
one reason storm and the next gens are
more efficient their ability to hold the
optimum racing line every single lap
with number three for the rookie
sensation storms in a class of his own
and a big reason for that training on
the newest cutting-edge simulators these
machines create a virtual racing
experience so real racers never even
have to go outside
storms ability to hold that line is like
nothing we've ever seen four in a row
are you kidding me who percent lower
drag coefficient five percent increase
downforce lucky number seven one point
two percent higher top speed hey Cruz oh
hey mr. sterling I'd like to introduce
you to Lightning McQueen here you're the
maestro mr. Stirling did you say
Lightning McQueen was here because I
don't see him anywhere uh but he's our
idea
do you know to see him nope still don't
see him he's right in front of you itch
Lightning McQueen e's obviously an
imposter
he looks old and broken-down Hey with
flabby tires I do not use that whoa
oh yeah I see I can use that energy from
motivation right it's all about
motivation mr. McQueen you can use
anything negative as fuel to push
through to the positive huh been pretty
positive ever since I was a rookie I am
so excited that I get to train you I
grew up watching you on TV huh is that
right these young guys are great and all
but I like a challenge
ha ha not that much older I call you my
senior project hey boys my speed I don't
know
I can only track you on the treadmill no
treadmills Oh what about Hamilton
Hamilton here who's Hamilton my
electronic personal assistant you know
like on your phone you do have a phone
don't you race cars don't have phones
cruise Hamilton track mr. McQueen speed
and reported tracking I'll stay as close
as I can your suit will transmit your
speeds to Hamilton fine whatever
Lightning McQueen first arrived hey
Bobby who is that that's um
Jackson storm yeah he's one of the
rookies not Percy get it thank you very
much thank you
hey Jackson storm right great race today
Wow
thank you mr. McQueen you have no idea
what a pleasure it is for me to finally
beat you
oh thanks wait did you say meet or beat
I think you heard me
Oh what do we get some pictures yeah
yeah come on let's get a picture
nobody get a ton of pictures because
champ here has been a role model of mine
for years now and I mean a lot of years
right I love this guy
I think I touched a nerve get ready for
what's coming more speed more of
everything
[Music]
this is my last chance if I lose I never
get to do this again
[Music]
don't fear failure be afraid of not
having the chance you have the chance
[Music]
[Applause]
never be the racer you once were
you can't turn back the clock kid
you can wind it up again don't you worry
pal got a good run
I'm coming for you storm
all right turn up the heat
you are not winning this I decide when
I'm done
rated G
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you are about to become the biggest
brand in racing movie deals in
commercial product endorsements stretch
ow you think you're famous now will be
rich beyond belief mr. Serling what is
this about your legacy every time you
lose you damage yourself I'm sorry your
racing days are coming to an end
we can only hope that this race today
wasn't his last I decide when I'm done
how you feeling I can't go out on the
track and do the same old thing it won't
work it's futile to resist change man
you know what I do what I don't know
I got nothing I am so excited to train
you I like a challenge
uh-huh I call you my senior project on
your nod that is sad the beach ate me
Jackson storm set a new record today
when he pulled off the fastest lap at
ever recorded how you feel seen the
latest record scores concern we give it
any doctorate when a queen
this is my last chance Cruz last if I
lose I never get to do this again don't
fear failure be afraid of not having the
chance you have the chance I used to
watch you on TV flying through the air
you seemed so fearless
it was shiny wood that felt like
[Music]
you'll never be as fast to store but you
can be smarter than him
Racing is the reward at the stop drug
scandal
our ninety five point two percent
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you'll never be the racer you once were
you can't turn back the clock kid
[Applause]
we are so excited to launch the road to
the races tour here at Disney springs in
Walt Disney World this tour has
something for absolutely everyone I need
to hear the excitement excitement this
is where it can take a photo with our
characters cruise
she's our new leading lady in this film
she's a fierce technician that's gonna
get Lightning McQueen prepared to go
into competition he's gonna be facing
off against Jackson's storm he's a
next-gen racer this guy is built to be
in beatable he's very confident rookie
sensation if you're feeling competitive
today you can get off to the races
we have Lightning McQueen and Cruz
Ramirez diecast models that you can race
down a ramp on the other side of this
experience you can play with the latest
and greatest toy set from the towels and
cars 300c crest oral-b is the perfect
place to spin the wheel win a prize and
get a photo at the star of car Street
Lightning McQueen make sure you have
your taste buds ready to try something
that's really fantastic a duel we're so
excited for guests to be able to try
amazingly themed smoothie this one is
inspired by Lightning McQueen can also
learn about the recipe behind them as
well at Alamo we have a mural wall that
everyone can come out color and bring to
life a photo of all the characters of
cars we have some artists up here we've
partnered with NASCAR acceleration
nation this is really gonna educate
folks on the math and science behind
NASCAR a really cool activity that you
can do today is create a 3d model of
some of the stars of the film and then
if you're really feeling super creative
you can create your ariane car right
here cool make sure you stop by the
Coppertone booth we have a variety of
sunscreen for everyone to try our new
copper total whipped this is my personal
favorite right now the pit crew
challenge all right come on you guys
whatever has look like nothing on there
at the end of 30 seconds oh wow I don't
know if you guys have ever seen
something like this before this is
absolutely amazing all right head on in
then a transformer mobile movie theater
is going to show gas 13 minutes of
footage from the film it's the footage
that no one has ever seen before an
excuse
to the road to the racist or we're so
excited to have the road to the racist
who are traveling to 27 cities this
summer next up we have Miami and we're
going to other cities like Philadelphia
New York Chicago San Diego and Denver
just to name a few head on over to car
seat or comm to check out the locations
and dates in your area and make sure to
check out the film and it hit theaters
June 16th see you there
[Music]
down
- hi
ready to watch huh
or horse lover
for everything
we'll never be the racer you once were
you can't turn back the clock
you can wind it up again
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you will never be the racer you once
were except it will Michel McQueen
retire I decide when I'm done
Jackson storm is part of the next
generation of high tech racers we're
number three for the rookie sensation
you'll never be as fast but you can be
smarter you need my help mr. McQueen
I'm coming for you storm
[Applause]
[Music]